hi guys I'm Grady
oh did you crazy on Instagram it's in
the gamer on twitch hey Tony Tony yes
Tony yes
shadow of the day for patreon with spri
free actually she contributed enough to
get her own personally requested video I
noticed so we might be doing that for
you spree just send me a message Jim
we'll go ahead and take care of that for
give you a full shot at the end spree
Call of Duty World War 2 I know a little
thing about World War 2 that's where
they fought that that bad guy the dude
the Charlie Chaplin but yeah they
actually fought Charlie Chaplin because
he was enslaving all the Jews in the
pyramid just gonna do the Moses lonely
man he's doing all this yeah I know my
history yeah
biggie ate together cool a tent he's a
cool hat funny funny guy yeah this day
is finally mighty endeavor
souls will be figured with the
violence's of war in this hour of great
sacrifice Wow any private bride
[Music]
we are always said like the world food
of the enemy is music and we must not
tire you'll be first
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
later on many casual you go you have to
confirm this is Divya
[Music]
we can tell them what we're all about
no mission too difficult welcome to the
body first you're a long way from Texas
one boy yeah Elena's in Texas a 3rd
November everywhere now in Jackson from
Bailey miss Reed November and say Nathan
you said Nathan there's a lot more
letters than anything exhibiting at all
you know what I didn't read that you
were thinking spider-man two's release
date way back one I think this makes
second one of those month books on
well that was some great [ __ ]
graphics that was some great great
graphics I'm not familiar with the Call
of Duty game all that well I know most
people play it for the gameplay this
looks like it's pretty heavy on
character though I'm gonna just go far
out there with this whole thing I've
been in playing these games for so long
it's like Call of Duty started with like
the beginning ones on PlayStation it's
so funny because they went from having
like games like this where it was about
the war and then they got into modern
workers yeah they stuck to like the same
thing for like a long time and then all
of a sudden like I feel like that one
game of time Falls where you had
jetpacks came out and then they started
going with advanced warfare but then
battlefields came and what about that
one went back and everyone was loving
that and they're kind of overall the
futuristic yeah and I feel like I just
jump in about to be like yo we still
make some bad shooter games that aren't
all futuristic so it's great that is
going back to like this old time I go
World War 2 or similar to how
battlefront is there's and stuff is it
battlefront battlefield a battlefield I
mean you get a like a really in-depth
story where it's like oh man this might
actually be a person that died on the
field but the graphics with graphics are
incredible is like you were watching an
actual movie man when I saw a
battlefield trailer
I had remember having a very specific
opinion
and I feel very I feel even stronger
towards this one when I even I say this
it's a weird experience for me to be
like I really want to play good like I
want to take the controller i would like
it like you have it I'll play it with
you gentlemen
so I want to pick the controller of
however I feel a little strange field
being like I want to have so much fun
playing this game that's based on a real
war where some people are still alive
from world war ii is such a heavy part
in history and such a graphic
traumatizing violence time for so many
people and to make it into a fun game
that teenagers have you playing I'm
wondering how will I really really feel
right playing this game enjoy like all
of in the war I'm just killing people
and [ __ ] like this real people that the
250 now think that that moral game over
that step that it's like are these
actual people I feel like you'll kind of
go after like a wild planet I in Call of
Duty's always done some kind of like
crazy stuff we're like while you're
playing you're like this is actually
pretty crazy like the airport level that
you have played and we'll just call it
like a world from Modern Warfare 2 or 3
where you literally go through an
airport and just gunned down people with
the holes yeah the mission they've
gotten so graphic out I don't feel like
they just felt a bit like people are
gonna be like oh man my grandpa's still
alive exact moment they're just going to
be like damn so indebted like the game
and that was the number one gun game
shooter game yeah so long and I felt
like I don't feel that's really started
to give them a run for the money when
it's strict certain shooters that they
come out with I don't know man they
might let me back with this one it's
just it's just a concept of making
something fun that is something so
tragic can happen the whole time you're
playing it man it might be fun for like
the first two deaths and then like after
like seven or eight [ __ ] so
frustrating I gotta get past this part
it looks like it's honoring the theme of
our soldiers well it looks like they
have actual real good character here
they show like emotional moments
throughout this trailer so it doesn't
seem like it's just becoming like some
action movie type of game well it's
going to fill
that one you're starting to see actual
like actors because yeah I got they're
so good with the motion detector now
they're like you're going to see actual
performances I don't even know who's on
the game right now but I'm pretty sure
when you're playing about the fun I know
that is John Malkovich depending on how
long the game play is getting an
experience that goes way further than a
movie does so you don't feel like after
two hours they feel like you get in a
movie go you can really like expand this
story out for a long that it would be
very crazy if they went with an actual
here so I feel you're gonna get like a
made-up character from probably text
family or something like that and it's
cool too and at the same time though I
mean these games are so detailed now
that it could probably give you an
insight into what the war really looked
like from the inside out you know on the
battlefield when you like died in the
story mode like they show the name of
the guy yeah I remember that I don't
know the hell that's pretty crazy with
like they'll actually be like no this
was an actual person yeah yeah that was
like the crazy part of playing that game
I don't know if it'll be like that on
this game because then they'll be really
- straight copy and give her game
however you know with everything I said
about it being fun and like being kind
of questionable about my own weird moral
integrity I still think it will probably
be a blast to play and I think killing
some Nazis ain't such a bad idea to put
in a video game
one of the last thing I'm saying for
this game is that I hope they take what
a battlefield does just like they make
an environment where if you destroy
something like if you destroyed a
building and not like one of the levels
the building will fall down I just hope
like finally Call of Duty starts
implementing and to like their games
where it's like you destroy something
they'll actually like do damage to the
Maverick by the end of the map like
there's a like the whole place looks
different from when he's pretty muddy
now don't go that is cool yeah make it
as realistic as possible more realistic
we can make World War 2 the more fun
it'll be that's an actual person hey
guys subscribe to the real rejects
trees on Instagram it's in the game in
arms which shout-out again
just free will be doing your specially
requested video keep a lookout for that
not beautiful sexy spray Thank You spree
I would like to have a three was free
you being the number three oh I thought
John would be like yeah I get jealous
you probably just want him the whole
time he's so sexy she needs to feel like
50% attracted to me 50% attracted to you
make it a full three we get to this
point because his hair ran beautiful
house you're not going to be more than
50% yeah you look really Indian your
part in you I'm in you are a Native
American took your land how yeah and
then so on and then and then you go to
our casinos employee money yeah but that
try was like a scene is hot be it to
forgot about the and they're probably
gonna just like start going pipelines
through all of our shoes making fun out
of real life